hello my name is sarah e colitis
and i'm here at the virtual roche
discovery global user symposium
to discuss the application of discovery
amp
hq kit technology at novovita histopath
laboratory llc
on the agenda today i'm going to start
by discussing
nobody and what we do then give you some
background
on the amp hq tsa protocol
from there i'll move on to examples of
ihc
versus hq comparison staining
and then share many successful examples
of standing using the amp hq technology
noble vita histopath laboratory llc
is a contract research organization or
cro
based in boston massachusetts providing
a variety of histopathology services
as well as automated ihc and automatic
automated
whole sighting
of that wide variety and full spread
that we provide
and break it down into four separate
categories
in the histology section we do
processing embedding sectioning h
e and special staining for molecular
pathology
there's ish fish rna
soap and dna extraction from ffpe
samples we have a
whole span of bio sample services from
creating and storing blocks
in tmas as well as control slides
what i'm really going to be focusing on
here today is our ihc capability
where we have automated staining with
single and multiplex
immunohistic chemistry ihc in whitefield
as well as immunofluorescence if we also
do automated image analysis
from these stains with
and tissue analysis all of this is
available with both human and non-human
tissue samples
we have expertise in this whole array of
surfaces
part of our range of state-of-the-art
equipment in our facility
are two members of the roche tissue
diagnostics research platform
we have the discovery xt and the
discovery ultra
both of these platforms provide rate
reliable reproducible automated iep
staining
as well as possibility to optimize very
specific and specialized
staining protocols required by our
clients
so now to the fun part actually talking
about sustaining itself
when a client comes to us because we are
a cro
we are based on client projects
when the client comes to us we start by
optimizing a standard
ihca and this assay
is as efficient as we can on
an ultra or an xt on the ventana
platform
where you have every antibody either
from a vendor or something specialized
and then a secondary antibody
which will then be conjugated with hrp
that reacts
to the chromos brown substrate and give
you a single
brown color
ideally this standard ic
it will give you a nice strong stain
that is
representative of what's happening on
the tissue
however that's not always the case
sometimes that standard ihc has a lot of
background
where it's very faintly stained and
difficult to detect
when that happens we
bring in our amp hq
discovery hq kit from rose tissue
diagnostics
for our ihc with hq version of the
protocol
this is a teramide signal amplification
or tsa technology where the hrp
activated ceramide
binds to using residues on tissue
then detection happens with the anti-h
region
and substrate when where we are then
able to put on the
chromosome the same chromatid vab that's
used in the standard ihc
so you see here on the left the standard
ihc
that i described in the last slide
and on the right it's showing
it's the same way with that primary
antibody specific to the project
the secondary antibody with the hrp
conjugated to it
but then as we move over even further
right
the hrp reacts with the teramine
deposits the influence of tissue
another antibody comes in that's
specifically targeted to that
hq which is enzymatically linked
to another substrate which will react to
the chroma map
and deposit the chromogen onto the
tissue
giving us an improved signal on a low
signal
stain or reducing our background
so that's the theory how do you put it
into play well
hopefully since this is a user symposium
you have seen the screen before
this is our create new protocol screen
on the discovery platforms
the one i'm showing you here is for the
discovery
ruo and hitting
the create edit protocol button brings
you this
blank screen three check boxes are
available
the first sequence the counter stage and
the side
cleaning when you're setting up a
protocol you're going to start with that
first sequence
by clicking that button you'll open up a
full
range of protocol variables that you're
able to enter into your ihc staining
protocol
things like faking and departurization
and inhibiting endogenous peroxidases
as well as the primary antibody
application
and incubation time that's something
you need to figure out whether it's a
standard ihc
or an amp hq ihc assay
what i'm focusing on today and what i
just showed you in the previous slides
comes after that primary antibody
first off is this little box called
multiple hrp this is your
secondary antibody that comes in
conjugated with hrp
when you click the box it will give you
options to select
which multiplayer hrp reagent you wish
to use
there are on the map and ultra map
options
and what you really need to look for
here is what species your primary
antibody
is is it a rabbit is it a mouse and then
select the appropriate one
from the box as shown on the right
from here you can then go to the dav
encounter state and that's how you
create a standard ihd assay protocol
however if you need that extra boost
that amplification
you're going to move to a check box a
couple more below
and that's the discovery amplification
selection
the discovery amplification comes as a
kit
and you have a couple dispensers in it
you're going to have the discovery amp
tsa hq and the discovery amplification
h202hq
where you need to set the incubation
time
and then you also need to decide which
discovery multimeter to use
you've heard me say here we're using the
hq version
so of the three that i have available as
options on the right
the anti-bs is not the one we're using
here
the two hq options are ap
and hrp
and which one you choose depends on what
homogeneous
for your final assay the most commonly
used one
is the dad which is often from the
chroma mat
kit very reliable very commonly used the
centennial line there are some
needs for an at detection when you're
not
using a corona dav
or as you'll see soon the range of
non-daily chromogens available from the
ventana ones
that are hrp activated
this is a great example of what moving
from an
ihc standard ihc protocol to an
amp hq protocol looks like on the right
we have the first run of this immune
cell antibody staining on
syngenic mouse spleen project
with that standard ihc protocol we get a
weak signal
we can see that there are positive cells
but they're not
popping in the way we really expected to
be able to analyze these immune cells
so we added an amplification step we did
that amp
hq and we
also realized that the end game of this
particular
thing i'm going to be multiplexing and
when you multiplex you're adding more
than one
antibody onto the tissue on a single
slide and you need to use
different colors for the different
antibodies
for this particular target
we're not going to be keeping the brown
we decided to switch to a purple
so in the process of adding the
amplified
signal with the amp hq kit we also
switch our chromogen from dav
with the colonnet kit to the discovery
purple hrp
which is what you see here on the left
beautifully showing
distinct purple immune cells
in a field of the counter-stained
hemotoxin nuclei
here's another example of some of our
standard optimization
sequences this happens to be a tumor
cell
antigen staining on human endometrial
carcinoma
in the middle you'll see our initial
pass with the optimization
the standard ihc we have some very
weak brown staining on the membrane of
the tumor cells
and if we had continued with this we
feared we'd get a lot of
false negatives in the project
we decided to add that amplification
step and by keeping
the dilution of that primary antibody
consistent
and simply adding in that hq
implementation step
we were able to get distinct brown
staining
that didn't look very faded to really
visualize what the tumor cells were for
expression levels
because we are scientists we do make
sure to run our negative controls
and that's what you see all the way on
the base this is
our rabbit igg running negative controls
ihc assays make sure that you use an igg
that's a consistent species
with the species of your primary
antibody in this case rabbit
at the same concentration using the
amplification hq kit and we see a nice
negative stain compared to our am hq
staining all the way on the left
however you may be able to notice
depending on how your screen is
but there is a faint brown blush in our
rabbit igg
just based on the tissue itself
this did not concern us because this was
our hq
version and we could easily read around
that area and see the
real scening was however if this was
negative control
to the panel our standard ihc
much of what would have been considered
positive with that ihc
would have been the same as our negative
control meaning that
our fear of false negatives
was very valid and moving to the end
page
was the right move for this particular
project
we are also able to use this technology
in
more self-face skating tumor tissues or
immune cells within the tissue here's a
pbmc sample with a phosphorus
correlated antibodies and i'm sure many
of you in the crowd
have dealt with the trials and
tribulations of dealing with
phosphorylated antibodies they're not
the easiest ones to deal with
and with our standard ihc we have really
weak
signal however putting in that amp
hq sequence we have a very strong
distinct brown stain we're able to
detect which of these pbmcs
are positive and which are negative
here's another great example of not
needing to
use dav to have the same
ihc standing using the centennial
and when using the amphu kit
here's strong signal detection with
purple
on a non-small cell carcinoma sample
we're able to see distinct membranes
staining around the tumor cells
differentiated
from your blue hematoxylin nuclei
i have heard some questions about the
nearness
in color between a purple hematoxylin
in a purple color when you choose your
chromogen
so it's definitely something worth
considering as you put your protocol
together
which hematoxylin you're using how blue
it can be how purple it can be
and the amount of bluing time that you
use
i believe there are two different
hemitoxins that contain that provides
human toxin one
and contact one two and each level has
their own preference
so be sure when you're switching from
around to a different color to really
keep that in mind
of what your counter state will look
like
now i'm going to talk about different
types of projects we've seen
and used the amp kit for for this one
project the client came to us with a
batch of
archive slides or blocks
not quite sure it could be slides or
blocks either way they were very
old ffpe samples and they were
poorly preserved by the time we got our
hands on them
we started with the traditional ihc our
standard hc
and there was no signal for the target
we were interested in but there was a
lot of background stating
this is the one on the left where we
have that nuclear stain
a little bit of a blush in between we
weren't going to
be able to detect what we knew was going
to be a
small low amount of signal
antigen we moved to this 3 amp
hq kit which helped us
minimize that background staining remove
that nuclear staining
and be able to clearly identify that
low-level positive antigen staining
as you can see in the highlighted box on
the right
another type of study that we've done
for a client
is for detecting drug cross reactivity
in normal and target tissue
in this project the client gave us
different batches
of samples some of which had been
exposed to the drug some which had not
some which were two were and some which
were normal organs
and we were to confirm if the
antigen of interest was present
in which batches of sample
hoping of course that the antigen of
interest
only in the targeted tissue exposed to
the
drug here are two great examples of what
came out of that project
on the left is a sample
that was completely negative and had
never posed to the drug
on the right is a sample
that was exposed to the drug and
displays
drug specific binding
and the assay that we used for this
finding
was the tsa technology with the amhq
so looking at a single scene is very
useful but sometimes you need a little
bit more context from a single slide
and in that case you're going to use a
multiplex protocol
using the ventana system you're able to
sequentially add additional antibodies
after that first sequence
and where you're going to be doing that
is in that same crate edit protocol
screen that i showed you earlier
at the end of the first sequence right
before your counter stain
you select dual sequence you can keep
going
down and down triple quadruple i believe
at the last update there's
seven or eight you're able to add in
sequence in that way
so here's an example where we went to a
dual scene from our single
and one of the most efficient ways to do
that is by
keeping your scanning from a single
optimized assay in this case
on the cd8 we're keeping it with that
homo map
dav brown stain and simply
adding the optimized protocol for our
cd19
but switching from the dav to the teal
the teal is also a therapy activated
as a chromogen so you don't have to
change any of the leaking antibodies
above it
for it to give this great robust stain
here's another example of the same idea
we start off with connecting four single
optimized
assay with the brown dav
using that mhq kit i wanted to see
another antibody on the same
slot in this case instead of the tail
it's a purple
purple is also an hrp activated
chromogen
which has very robust reliable
performance
and is my second choice might be the
same
level as teal they're my two most used
non-brown chromogens as i start to
create complex protocols
multiplexers is limited to bright fields
and homogeneous
and neither is using this amphit
technology to really boost your staining
intensity
we've had success with using it
in immunofluorescent assays as well
here's a great tumor example where we're
looking at
cd4 in green cd8 and red
and we
moving from two color multiplex to three
this is a great example of a project
that came
from a client interested in three
separate
specific antigens which they knew
were prominent in the type of tissue
however they were interested in what the
distribution
actually is are all three antigens
on the same cells do they have patches
within the tumor
and how about that really makes you
think of
how to construct this type of product
where you're able to look at each
antigen separately
and also any coexpression
so the colors we chose for this protocol
were teal purple and yellow that's
because they're very distinct colors
individually and helpfully
they allow for a new color
when they are co-expressed so the teal
and the purple
co-expressed on a cell give this rich
dark blue which you're seeing
here all throughout the tissue
and there are very few cells which are
strictly purple
or strictly teal get that rich blue
color
when purple and yellow are close for us
we give an orange
which we have one or two cells here not
that many
in this particular project we were able
to explain for this sample
that the antibody one and the antibody
to coexpress
all antibodies three that yell beyond
different
cells and if yellow and two
were together it would give you this
green cell
keeping that co-expression in mind and
adding more colors here's the example of
looking at a tumor micro environment
where we have these cell types that
we're
looking at we're not actually interested
in the collagen
we want to be able to see each color to
60.
so this cd4 is in brown which will not
do a coexpression color with the cd8 in
purple
c and cd19 are different different cell
plates so they're not going to be
co-expressed
and the blue is a monocyte which i've
highlighted here because they are a
little
bit difficult to find if you're not
looking for them
they're all being separate colors so
sometimes when you're multiplexing
with this amp hq you need that whole
expression
like in the previous slide and sometimes
you need them distinctly separate
like in this slide and you have to pick
your chromogens accordingly
looking at slides one by one is a very
helpful way to get
quick context about that pure slide but
we get a lot of projects
through here that need bigger picture
answers than just a one by one
by slide type of description and for
that we move on to tmas
we had a project recently
where it was a low express antigen
on a panel of tumor heights and
this client interested in knowing what
the key patterns are
for their particular subtype that had
high expression versus
low expression and we are able to do
that
by using an amphitheater to detect that
low signal antigen
and then use automated whole slide
imaging
and image analysis to create a
tma map screening for indications
and evaluating the incidence of diseases
in those diseases of interest for the
client
another piece of our state-of-the-art
capabilities
is high quality
100x oil whole side imaging giving us
up nice and close cellular views
of the tissue we are
sometimes using our amp hq kit
technology when staining these samples
and at 100x oil you're still getting
nice
crisp stain it doesn't become fuzzy or
indistinct we still get that nice crisp
staining
on top of that a nice 100x oil allows
for
these stacking images where you get a
better three-dimensional feel
of how the cells are in space
on that tissue as you can see here
on the left we have that nice crisp
cellular look
and on the right still a very pretty 100
x
image but without that added context
that is the stacking allows
so in summary i presented on the
application of
the discovery amp hq technology
at novovita novovita histopath
laboratory is a cro located
in boston massachusetts specializing in
automated histopathology services
including high quality
immunohistochemistry the discovery
amp hq kit provides sensitivity of ihc
assay compared to the standard ihc
assays
which helps to reduce background
and improve signal the
discovery amp hq kit protocols can be
used for a variety of project types
including but not limited the ones i've
described here such as looking at tumor
antigens
reducing backgrounds on old poorly
preserved samples
produced in tmas in both single stained
and
multiplexed assays
before i wrap up i would give a huge
shout out of thanks to the nova
histopath team telling andrew chris
julian
selena and justin were a big help of
putting this presentation together
and finally i been sari elitist
i hope you've learned how to use the faq
kit
and it can provide to your ihc staining
thank you very much for your attention
and i hope you enjoyed the roast
discovery
global user symposium